Are you being chased by a small black bear or a cat?
[Music] [
Applause]
There's no way I'll leave you behind.
If you're injured, you're
fine.
Anyway, those bears and cats from earlier were
cute. They're
not hard on you, really.  I'm sure I was
chased all the way around here, but I
came back.
Something like that. Did something like this happen the
last time I passed by? No, I'm
so happy. I want to stay here and
enjoy a blissful time surrounded by bears and cats, but that's not going to happen.
Welcome.
Thank you
very much. [Applause] That's not good. I think I
surprised you. If I get
separated from the bears and cats here, I don't know when I'll be able to see people again. In
that case,
[Applause]
Things have changed.
Everyone be careful.
[Music]
Hey,
run away.
[Music] Is
this smelly meat?
[Music]
Please add a welcome effect.
Maybe it's a box selling things. Watch out for the
score. It might be a trap of the type that takes you with food. Do
n't
get too close to the bell.  It's no good, even the short ones will
keep a certain distance, but look at them.The
names of the bear cats have been revealed.
Look at the slender leader. The one with
drooping ears is the shovel. The chubby one is
Pel, and the brown one is
short.  Well, let's
eat now. Have you
forgotten the pride of being a member of the pack that called me the hungry gluttonous devil? I
thought it looked like something, but then I realized it
was a Tasmanian devil. I'm sure it's a carnivore.  It
was quite a big meal.